in this video i'm going to be breaking
down the fifth episode of attack on
titan season 4
in which willy tyber declared war on
parody's island only to be immediately
killed by the attack titan in aaron's
defense he wasn't the one who started
the war so it was totally fair game
this video will explain everything that
i thought was interesting about the
episode
including how willie already knew he was
going to die why the warriors were
tricked into getting captured
and the truth about the great titan war
before we get into it
i do these episode reviews every week so
i'd really appreciate if you hit the sub
button
and as usual let me know your thoughts
on the episode down below
okay so episode 5 was called declaration
of war and it begins with a brief
flashback to parodies island
during the time in which reiner annie
and bertolt were infiltrating the walls
they discussed the man who told them
about his past and the gang wonders why
he told them his story
for those that maybe forgot this man was
the only survivor of a village that had
been attacked by titans
and while he managed to escape his three
children were left behind
the guilt eventually became too much
with the man committing suicide
and bertolt theorizes that he told them
his story because he wanted someone to
judge him
the reason this flashback was put in
episode 5 was because this man's guilt
at leaving his children behind
is a direct parallel to the guilt that
reiner feels in the present day
if reiner didn't make the warriors
continue with their mission after marcel
died
then burlton might still be alive and he
might not have been captured
and he wouldn't have been the only one
to return home additionally
ryan's guilt is even more than just this
as when he was on parodies island he was
personally responsible
for the deaths of many aldians who he
then realized were not the devils he
thought they were
but rather they were just ordinary
people who didn't deserve what he did to
them
after the opening we see willie tiber
preparing for his stage production
where he will be declaring war on
paradise island in front of journalists
and diplomats from all around the world
unlike his usual confident self willie
is visibly shaken in this moment
and it's not because he's afraid of
public speaking in episode 4 of the
final season
commander mcgath informed willy that
there was an infestation of rats in mali
by which he meant that there were spies
from paradise island currently in the
country
following on from that there was an
important conversation in the manga that
was presumably taken out of this episode
for pacing reasons
but mcgath says it's highly likely that
spies from parodies will attack
during the big speech mcgath believed
that willy would die
because they don't know exactly how
their enemy will attack and therefore
it's hard to protect him when he's just
you know front and center on stage
despite that willie accepted his fate
and considers his death to be necessary
to show the world
the genuine threat of paradise island
his death will make the world feel
sympathy for both willie himself
and the innocent eldians in liberio who
would be killed
that's why in this moment willie is so
nervous because he knows he's not making
it out of this performance alive
he's then approached by miss kiyomi who
was the lady in the last episode that
saved udo from getting punished
she's an ambassador from the nation of
hizuru which is the only place that is
tolerant of eldians and she tells willy
that she hopes the production goes well
after this she leaves the area without
sticking around for the performance
which is probably for the best moving on
rainer comes face to face with erin in
this dimly lit cellar
and he can barely believe what he's
seeing aaron orders rhinos to sit down
as if he was taking her hostage
and you can see that falco is confused
by their reactions as i explained in my
last review
falco believes that these two guys are
old friends so reina's blank expression
is not exactly what he was expecting
aaron explains that the cellar they're
in
is underneath a regular apartment
building behind the stage which is
basically a thinly veiled way of saying
he's about to kill everyone i love
falco's innocence in this moment
like he truly has no idea what's going
on as if this man is not about to go
full titan mode in a few minutes
obviously reiner is aware of the
situation so he complies with aaron's
request to sit down
followed by an awkward silence in which
falco offers to leave
however eren tells falco to stay and
listen to his story which was a mean
thing to do considering that aaron knows
he's about to blow this place up
did those letters mean nothing to you
the crowd continues to get seated for
the performance
and we get a brief interaction between
rhino's mother and annie's father
in season 1 we saw in a flashback how
annie's father made her promise to
return home from the mission
which is why she was crying as she was
about to be captured her father believes
that she must still be alive
because of the promise she made to
return home although reina's mother is
understandably not so sure
the leaders of mali's military were also
sitting by this point
and it was willie tiber's request that
all the leaders were grouped together as
close as possible
because willy knows the enemy is going
to attack he put the leaders in this
section as bait
so that they could be wiped out by the
enemy and then mcgath could rebuild the
military from scratch
just before the curtain rises an alden
soldier approaches the warriors of mali
and asks them to leave because commander
mcgath has summoned them we then go back
to eren falco and reiner
as the vice captain of the warriors
finally musters up the courage
to ask aaron what he came here to do
aaron replies in epic fashion
by telling reina that he came to do the
same thing that reiner did himself
which is referring back to the attack on
the walls all those years ago
falco is still totally in the dark about
what's going on but ryan begins to freak
out
as he realizes what's about to happen
aaron says he's doing this because he's
the same as reiner
and he doesn't have any other choice but
what eren doesn't know at this point
is that reiner did have the choice to
stop the mission back in the day
but continued on because he wanted to be
a hero
meanwhile the performance of willie
tiber begins and along with the help of
his cast and crew
he tells the story of how the alden
empire took over the world with the
titans
after their ancestor yumiya gained the
power i did a video explaining how ymir
got her titan powers if you're
interested but willie goes on to explain
how the eldin empire destroyed
so many races and cultures along the
road to world domination
around 100 years ago the great titan war
began and this was a period of civil war
within the aldian empire at that time
the royal family possessed the founding
titan
and the eight other titans were
separated among eight noble families
as willie goes on to say the story that
most people are told is that there was a
malian named helos who was the hero that
saved the world
as he formed an alliance with the tiber
family and forced the king to retreat to
parody's island
whilst on the island people thought that
the king continued to reign
and believed that if the island was
threatened the king would order the
colossus titans in the walls
to crush the world as an audience we
know this could not be further from the
truth
because when the series began the king
of parodies island was a fake
and even the true royal family couldn't
use the full extent of the founding
titan
so in short nobody was going to be
destroying the world while the
performance continues
the soldier who approached the warriors
tells zeke to go to the front gate
and he's porco and peak to a different
location it should be said that peak is
arguably the most observant
and possibly the most intelligent of all
the warriors and you can tell that she's
slightly suspicious of the soldier in
question
in the manga willie told magath that
they need to be careful of traitors who
have aligned with parodies island
and the military is no exception we see
this play out here
as the soldier leads the two warriors
into a secluded property
before cutting the rope on a trapdoor
and allowing the two to fall down into a
shaft
in just one motion this soldier has
trapped two of the warriors
which will give eren more freedom to
attack later in the episode
before we move on there are two things
to mention number one is that peak
hugged a member of the panzer unit
before she was trapped
and these guys are the ones who sit on
top of the cart titan with their machine
guns
the other thing is that by this point in
the episode we saw a couple times have
mcgath is observing everything that's
happening on stage
but he hasn't yet realized that the
warriors are not where they're supposed
to be
back in the cellar falco begins to think
about why reiner looks so frightened
and questions who exactly mr kruger is
because aaron claimed he was reiner's
old friend
falco realizes that if they knew each
other for so long aaron might be from
paradise island
on stage willie tiber's performance
takes an interesting turn
as he begins to reveal the truth about
the great titan war thanks to the
memories of the warhammer titan
the tigers know what really happened
back in the day and it is way different
from the story that people are told
it turns out that the man who ended the
great titan war was neither hellos
nor was it the tiber family instead it
was carl fritz
who was the 145th king of the eldian
empire unlike previous eldian kings
carl was ashamed by their violent
history and felt sympathy for the nation
of mali which was one of the nations
conquered by the first founding titan
he'd also grown tired of the civil war
between the noble families
and so once he inherited the founding
titan he conspired with the tibers
to bring the empire to an end it was
revealed in the last episode
that the tigers had secretly been in
control of mali since the great titan
war and along with their safety
these were the things that they gained
by working with the king culprits moved
as many aliens as he could to the island
of paradise while the nation of mali
acquired seven out of the nine titans
fritz then threatened the world to not
attack the island or else he would
unleash the massive colossus titans but
woody reveals to everyone
that that threat was a lie fritz said
those things so that he could maintain
peace on the island
however if they were to be attacked then
he would accept it as revenge for elders
crimes
the king made a binding vow to renounce
all war which is why his successors such
as friederich and yuri rice
were unable to use the full power of the
founding titan they were always
overtaken by carl fritz's ideology
and so even when titans were attacking
their people the vow renouncing war
prevented them from doing anything
this meant that all the founding titans
since carl fritz have been powerless
against enemy invaders
with one notable exception aaron yeager
is not a person of royal blood
and therefore he is not restricted by
fritz's ideology
while it's true that aaron can't use the
power of the founding titan at will
we saw in season 2 that when he makes
contact with the titan of real blood
he can control the founders full
abilities willie tiber is aware that
aaron possesses this titan and declares
to the world that everyone is in
immediate danger
because there is now a founding titan
who is not held back by the vowel
announcing war
willy's emotional speech continues as
commander mcgath is finally made aware
that the warriors have disappeared this
is a clear sign that the enemies are
about to attack
with poco and peak still being stuck
underground the reason they're not able
to turn into titans is due to the
cramped conditions
and even if they could transform they
just end up crushing each other in the
process so
it wouldn't be worth it in the cellar
aaron whips out his amputated leg
and begins regeneration over the last
couple weeks i had a bunch of people
asking me why aaron's leg hasn't healed
yet and the answer is that he was
choosing not to do so because as we saw
in the past
titan shifters can delay their healing
process if they want to
by this point falco totally realizes
he's been tricked and you got to feel
bad for him because
he was genuinely encouraged by mr
kruger's words and he thought the two
had formed a real friendship
erin reveals that the letters falco sent
for him were not for his family like he
claimed but instead they were for his
friends
reiner briefly ponders what that could
mean before the scene switches over to
willie tiber who explains to the world
that aaron has the potential to activate
the rumbling willy's logic
is that to eliminate the threat from
parody's island they need to stop aaron
before he has a chance to activate the
titans in the walls
aaron even admits to falco and reiner
that it is a possibility that he could
do this
he says that while he's the bad guy now
reina annie and belto were the bad guys
to him
when they breached the walls all those
years ago and caused his mother to be
eaten
when questioned reiner claims they only
breached the walls to rotate the
founding titan
and save the world in the process you
can see that eren almost takes pity on
reiner as he did earlier in the episode
and he says that reiner must not have
had a choice both of these men used to
believe
that the people across the ocean were
the enemy but after spending a lot of
time in mali
aaron came to realize that all aldians
are the same there are both good
and bad people on both sides of the
ocean and to eren
reiner was just an ignorant kid who
didn't know what he was doing when he
breached the walls
this is the moment when rhino really
loses it and reveals the truth to aaron
after all these years
which is that the mission was going to
be abandoned after marcel's death
and the only reason why everything
happened was because reiner convinced
them to continue
part of that reason was that rhino
wanted to survive but as he admits here
he also wanted to be a hero that people
respected it wasn't his age or his
environment that made him make that
decision
so reiner actually takes responsibility
and asks erin to kill him
definitely not how falco thought this
reunion would go but life comes at you
fast
meanwhile willie tiber gets the crowd on
his side by admitting that the danger
facing the world is due to the alien
race
and that if it was up to him he would
have chosen never to have been born
that said because he was born willie now
doesn't want to die
understandably and he encourages all
other nations that want to live
to join hands with mali and ensure a
future together
honestly this was a great speech because
he knows that people hate aldians
so he's admitting their faults but at
the same time unifying everyone against
a common enemy
in the cellar aaron asks a suicidal
rhino to stand up
and says that he finally understands him
like reiner
aaron is also a person who keeps moving
forward until his enemies are destroyed
and without hesitation he activates his
titan transformation
just as willie declares war on parody's
island i absolutely love the slow motion
in this moment
and it was also a bit unlucky for those
soldiers who were standing right outside
the door
the attack titan manifest itself
completely destroying the cellar that
reiner and falco were in
as well as the building full of
civilians aaron emerges in front of
diplomats and journalists from all
around the world before crushing the
stage and willie tiber
with his bare hands this moment is so
iconic
so it was great to see it finally
animated and yeah in my opinion i think
it was done
incredibly well let me know what you
guys think in the comments down below
and as usual i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like if you like this video
and share it with anyone who you think
might enjoy it thanks for watching and
until the next one
peace out